hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
Joe Scarborough is still pulling [ __ ]
out of his ass
he actually has one big thing is Biden's
winning streak President Biden has been
racking up wins racking up win after win
this is a big big win big victory at the
White House look at this huge
accomplishment a list of accomplishments
for Joe Biden just seems to keep growing
he's he's on a roll it is a remarkable
record it's all moving in Joe Biden's
Direction he's got his aviators on
inflation is you know still a factor gas
prices are actually coming down and have
been coming down for almost two months
the inflation rate is incredibly high
but look at those jobs numbers on Friday
the unemployment numbers are remarkable
inflation reduction act great name now
for all of those who say President Biden
what are you going to do about inflation
you've got it covered stimulus package
nearly 2 trillion uh infrastructure and
jobs act 550 billion dollars chips and
science at 280 billion dollars and then
this package Mika which is Landmark I
mean
preventing world war three check more
oil drilling here gas prices plummeting
making more vaccines here covid he
survived it more clean energy here owls
our hearing check so far President Biden
doesn't seem to be getting a lot of
credit for this he hasn't explained it I
mean there's no question that Joe Biden
is on a roll legislatively on the
National Security front but he's getting
no credit for it if you look at our our
new poll I mean he's getting credit for
almost nothing any way you cut it even
Republicans have to admit this privately
and they are it's been a hell of a run